among all Sorcerers in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
there is one that is different from the
rest his name is Gojo satoro and he
exists in a realm entirely separate from
those around him operating in a league
of his own his capabilities and prowess
transcend any standard measure and even
his strongest adversaries are terrified
of him so in this video we'll be
explaining all of Gojo's forms in Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen starting with his early
life as a prodigy and finishing with his
strongest god-like forms so Toro Gojo
was born to the prestigious Gojo family
and it has been said that on the day he
was born the balance of power shifted he
was the first person in 400 years born
with both six eyes and the Limitless
technique the Limitless allows goju to
pretty much bring the concept of
infinity into reality allowing him to
manipulate and distort space at will on
the other hand his six eyes technique
grants him extraordinary perception and
further enhances all of his abilities
considering how broken these two are it
was enough to prompt those in power to
place a bounty on Gojo's head although
we don't know much about Gojo's
childhood we know that he could sense
tochi who has no cursed energy with toji
saying that it's the first and last time
anyone was able to sense him man even as
a child this guy was a complete monster
five more forms are left and the next
one is student Gojo at some point Gojo
enrolled in Jujutsu high and was put in
class with ghetto and shoko naturally
over the years he learned how to use his
innate Powers but wasn't yet at the
point where he actually understood them
nevertheless he was fully aware of his
own talents and was awfully smug about
them although this is one of Gojo's
weakest forms in this video even at this
point he was considered to be one of the
strongest Jiu Jitsu Sorcerers alive
however despite all of his power he was
still young and lacked experience which
was shown in his battle against toji
fushiguro while Gojo was returning from
a mission toji suddenly impales him for
behind which is already pretty weird
since Gojo should have been able to
sense him as the Fight Continues Gojo
realizes that he can't read toji's moves
due to him having no curse energy
despite his best efforts Gojo is
eventually defeated with toji slashing
his neck it was brutal from start to
finish the battle barely lasted a few
moments showing Gojo that he wasn't as
Invincible as he thought however in
hindsight this battle was the greatest
thing that happened to gocho as it led
him to becoming even stronger than ever
before which takes us to his next four
awakened kojo while he was slowly dying
on the ground Gojo gave up on fighting
back and instead focused all of his
energy on reversed cursed technique this
is a very complex technique that
basically turns cursed energy into
positive energy and is used to heal
human bodies Gojo wasn't the first
person to develop this power for example
his classmate shoko developed it before
him but was unable to teach Gojo as
learning it is different for every
sorcerer however at that moment on the
ground Gojo figured it out the code of
cursed energy this instantly put him
several tiers above where he was before
and once he was healed it was time for
his rematch against toji in this form
Gojo was visibly stronger and managed to
effortlessly dodge toji's attacks in
addition to his new healing abilities he
also figured out a way to combine his
room first curse energy with his
Limitless blue technique creating the
new red technique that's the same color
as the Subscribe button what a
coincidence maybe Gojo is telling you to
hit it anyway this new technique repels
all matter with powerful repulsive force
and has twice the destructive power as
blue when Gojo Unleashed this technique
toji was shocked and badly injured
prompting him to call Gojo a monster at
this point Dojo seems Unstoppable and
while laughing he proclaims that
throughout Heaven and Earth he alone is
the honored one what Gojo does next is
something neither touching nor the rest
of us could have ever imagined it uses
both his blue and red technique to
create the ultimate Hollow technique
purple this is the secret move known
only by few in the Gojo family and it
has the power to literally take the
target out of reality instantly erasing
everything it hits without exception
needless to say soji didn't survive this
okay you're probably wondering how can
there be three more forms left when goju
is already this powerful well I don't
know what to tell you this guy can get
his power powerful as he wants
apparently and he proves it in his next
form adult Gojo this is the version of
Gojo we see in season 1 and in the movie
Zero what makes this form different from
the previous one is the fact that Gojo
learned how to use his domain expansion
the infinite void domains are the
Pinnacle of Jujutsu and something that
not many Sorcerers are capable of
although Gojo already became the
strongest sorcerer when he awakened his
purple technique his domain expansion
put him in a completely different League
compared to anyone else even Jujutsu
higher-ups are scared of his power and
well aware that if goja turns against
them they wouldn't be able to stop him
at this point JoJo truly believes that
he is invincible and when Yuji asks him
if he'd be able to defeat full power
sukuna he confidently says that he would
the first time we see this version of
Gojo fight is in episode 7 when he is
ambushed by a special grade cursed yoga
after some unsuccessful attacks jogo
eventually uses his domain expansion
which prompts Gojo to show us his
infinite void is revealed and due to its
sheer power jogo's domain is easily
suppressed so what is it like to be
trapped inside Gojo's domain well it's
like being in a state of absolute
complete trance the domain repeatedly
feeds you with unlimited information so
you cannot think or move at all the only
thing you can do is just stand there
completely helpless until you eventually
die before we cover Gojo's strongest
form in the entire series let's first
cover Shibuya Gojo the Shibuya incident
was carefully planned by kanjako to be
Gojo's downfall it is the point in the
story where Gojo is put in an impossible
situation you see during this Arc Gojo
fought a bunch of strong cursed Spirits
now although this usually wouldn't be a
problem for him he had one big
disadvantage due to the many civilians
around him he couldn't activate his
domain expansion although Gojo was fine
without his domain and was winning
against the curses he realized that he
couldn't continue like this as there'll
be too many human casualties so Gojo
surprised everyone once again and did
something insane he managed to open his
domain for only 0.2 seconds making
everyone around him unconscious he did
this because he calculated that an
average human should be able to survive
0.2 seconds in his domain without any
lasting After Effects however this also
meant that stronger curses wouldn't be
permanently trapped in the domain only
unconscious for a few minutes this gave
him enough time to kill over 1 000
transfigured humans in Shibuya in less
than five minutes and save everyone
although Gojo didn't awaken any new
powers in this form he once again showed
incredible instincts and mastered his
abilities even further shortly after
this Gojo was tracked by kanjaku and
sent to the prison realm however this is
not the end of Gojo's development as
when he eventually gets out he engages
in the toughest Battle of his life
against none other than the king of
curses aryomin sukuna and you can bet he
gets even more powerful during this
fight unsealed Gojo as soon as Gojo is
unsealed from the prison realm he pays a
visit to kinjaku but just before killing
him supuna stops IT and the two of them
decide on a date for their fight 24th of
December soon the promise day arrives
now although Hollow purple by itself is
pretty broken in this fight Gojo takes
it to the next level you see utahima's
innate technique allows her to
temporarily amplify cursed energy of
other sorcerers so when she activated it
to help Gojo in his battle against
sukuna Gojo managed to release his
hollow purple technique at 200 of its
normal Power although this was a great
way to kick off the fight it doesn't
hurt sukuna enough and just burns off
his arm which is easily regenerating as
their Fight Continues we finally get to
see the long-awaited battle between
their domains unlimited void versus
malevolent shrine at first they seem
evenly matched but there's one big
problem for Gojo here if you see
malevolent Shrine is different from
other domain expansions because it
doesn't create a separate enclosed space
instead it has the ability to create the
domain without barriers which was
compared to an artist painting not on a
canvas but on air because of this
although they are technically evenly
matched kuna's domain goes beyond Gojo's
barrier and manages to break it from the
outside this is a big problem for gocho
as he is now completely exposed to
sukuna's slashes however once again Gojo
shows his genius as he starts creating
simple Shadow style domains in order to
quickly heal himself and continue
fighting but then he does something even
crazier instead of using his reverse
curse technique to heal himself from
damage he uses it to restore his
exhausted curse technique even Utah
freaks out when he sees this because it
shouldn't logically be possible at the
end of the chapter even the narrator
says that Common Sense will not Prevail
in this battle as with Gojo and sukuna
are inconceivably powerful another thing
that makes this form of Gojo stronger
than the previous ones is the experience
he acquired while being trapped inside a
prison realm we've seen this when he
managed to shrink his domain into a
really small size in order to make its
barriers stronger same as how the prison
realm is small but unbreakable as of
making this video the fight between Gojo
and sukuna is still ongoing but it's
clear that it's the greatest fight in
the entire Fire series so far and I
can't wait to see what goja will do next
click on this video where we explained
all 12 cursed Spirits in jiu Jutsu
Kaizen